we simulated Jason Tatum being drafted
number one overall by the 76ers in the
2017 draft to see if he would lead them
to a championship in his rookie season
Tatum averaged 20.6 points per game and
won Rookie of the Year the Sixers made
the playoffs and won their first series
versus the Hornets but fell short to a
LeBron leg calf Squad in five games in
his second season the Sixers had an
impressive run thanks to Tatum scoring
going up to 22 and a half points per
game he would help lead the Sixers to
the Eastern Conference Finals but would
lose to the Bucks in seven games in year
three Tatum went crazy he got buckets
dropping 27.7 points per game and made
his first all-nba team all while leading
his sixes to a 71-11 record Tatum and
the Sixers finally got over the hump
after beating the Bucks in an Eastern
Conference Finals rematch to face the
Denver Nuggets in the NBA Finals after
handling the nuggets in five games Tatum
got his first ring in his third season
how many championships do you think the
Duel of him being in Tatum would have if
the Sixers picked him back in 2017